for more on what may come from the
summit we turn to Michael Mazar he's a
senior political scientist at the RAND
Corporation welcome to the table nice to
be here
so to Ben's report what are you
expecting from this meeting a meet and
greet or something substantial so
something in between I think the meet
and greet is the most important part
just to see how they get along it's too
short of a summit and there's not been
enough preparatory work done to expect
some kind of grand bargain where
everything is resolved but there should
be at least a road map that they can
agree to with maybe some initial steps
in the right direction you talk about a
road map if you look back over time
maybe go back to 1994 or even 2005 we've
had negotiations but more with North
Korea what do we learn from that that
makes a certain and what needs to be
done now well a couple of things one is
that North Korea has an incentive to
draw these things out and and delay and
find ways to kind of stretch the
negotiations without actually giving up
what it's trying to achieve but the
biggest question right now is how
different Kim jong-un actually is there
are tantalizing signals that he really
cares more about the economic prospects
of his country than his father or
grandfather what he's willing to give up
to get that right is the situation is
that well not at once not at once the
question is and the president Trump's
referred to a process here so the
question is can you get some initial
concessions that give everybody a sense
that North Korea's moving in the right
direction and a clear plan for over a
number of years I think everybody who
studies this realizes it will take a
while but at least if we have some clear
milestones that were moving toward we'll
know we're moving in the right direction
and that ought to be enough out of an
initial summit Michael when the
president says that he doesn't need much
preparation for a meeting like this or
that he's been preparing for it his
entire life does that give him the upper
hand does that put him at a disadvantage
or perhaps neutral
I don't know that really makes a lot of
difference I think clearly Secretary of
Pompeo has been working with the North
Koreans very closely it sounds like they
have some at least initial statements
agreed and the North Koreans have given
some assurance of a handful of things
they're willing to agree to but one that
we know from summits is by far the most
important thing is the personal
chemistry between the leaders that comes
up whether they develop trust where
they actually like each other I don't
know if that's possible in this case but
that's the most important thing I'm
going to be looking for is whether the
two leaders seem to be getting along and
establishing a basis of trust that can
move forward we've heard some talk in
the last week about a rift between
Pompeo and Bolton how does that factor
in when those are two of the closest
advisors to the president right now on
North Korea right yeah I mean I don't
know to what extent that's true I think
the way it factors in is it just gives
the president a choice always in those
cases it comes down to the president's
decision and the president will side
with one of the other side of his or
potentially her administration and then
that'll that'll be it unless one of the
other of those people then tries to work
under the table to subvert negotiations
or what the other side is doing I don't
get the sense of President Trump would
tolerate that from anybody so I think
he's made his choice which is to try to
move forward you know we have an open
and democratic society here so we'll
know how successful or unsuccessful this
meeting is how do you think it will play
in North Korea not just with the
hardliners in Kim's regime but the
people will they ever even get a sense
of what is happening in Singapore so
it'll play in two ways one is the way
the regime there wants it to play which
is of course the dominant way they will
broadcast whatever message they want to
and the primary message will be the
United States we forced the United
States to come to the table and they
recognized us in ways they never have
before that'll be their primary message
but there is a lot of information
getting into North Korea these days and
there is a sense that the North Korean
people have economic demands that they
haven't had in the past so there'll be a
short term message but then the
longer-term development of this whether
the North Korean people begin to see
benefits out of it relief of sanctions
that will be the longer-term more
important way in which a message gets
through to the North Korean people all
right all eyes on Singapore Tuesday
Michel Mazar thank you very much as
always CBS News will bring you coverage
of the historic meeting in Singapore
starting with our Sunday broadcast we
will also have updates throughout the
summit Jeff Glor will anchor the CBS
Evening News from Singapore on Monday
and Tuesday